we are 12 hours from mexico city
in the high mountain region
[Music] it
is a marginalized area it is an indigenous area it
is an area that lacks
many resources to perform surgery
in this type of hospital
[Music]
I decided to bring medicine  low cost
easy access to rural areas with the
support of virtual reality
[Music]
american university
expert acp
find out what people
need he was referring to expanding the
problem with traditional anesthetics they
have some disadvantages
including high cost and
collateral or adverse effects
[Music]
any packaging
is placed virtual glasses are
adjusted according to the size of your
head and the virtual reality system is turned on
that is done with a
cell phone currently during the
operation I looked at the landscape  plants,
animals, rocks, and what is ecology,
relax with that, the surgery was already finished, a
few slight bites, but it was not like that,
tremendous pain for
normal for me a flu
we reduce the pain more than 50% in these
patients it gives patients a
great hope of survival it gives them a
better quality of life nothing makes me
feel like a satisfied person satisfied
with life satisfied with the
professional life that has given me  allowed me to
develop, give back to society
what it has generated for me
[Music]